allez avec moi ou
on va gagner la course
suite au championnat
allemand va rentrer d'autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi
mais les et je pense à 100 patent
tatouages j'ai envie de m'en faire un
nouveau qu'est ce que tu veux te faire
tatouer d'un an si tu veux bien
malheureux mais c'est idiot tu vas te
faire tatouer ça je pourrais
je pas exploser une posture quoi il ya
une chaussure tamoutoi basculer
rapidement créé un peu un ovni avec ses
lumières
il m'a pas donné le nom de tentes à
thouars inquiétant je leur fais pas ta
peloton quad il va te faire face mais
quoi alors il faut comme ce qui est
écrit sur ma moto je savais que tu avais
pas oublié j'ai jamais dit que j'avais
oublié j'ai dit que c'était pas
important ça les pousse tellement ça
c'est important
donc si jamais tu pouvais faire un seul
voeu se serait de remporter le
championnat cela rend ce qu'il dit de
cette façon en direct elle pouvoir
d'exaucer mans comme un génie
je vais essayer de faire mon possible
l'érudit regardes
tu avais dit que tu voudrais à la soirée
vraiment la chanson
à son monde il ya des soucoupes volantes
et dans le tien des motos trafiquées
tel moteur ne sera pas le rideau
oui mais
ce garçon est ce qu'il ya de mieux pour
toi
[Musique]
ça me va très bien s'ils viennent pas ce
soir non bien sûr que non je veux pas
qu'un seul ovni fiemme interrompre ce
moment